the nun delivers a twist at the end of
the movie that will have surprised many
moviegoers however originally the final
scene was going to be even more shocking
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'll be revealing the
incredible ending for the nun that we
never got to see plus I'll be explaining
some other fascinating changes from the
original script
make sure you stay till the end where
I'll also reveal the crazy decisions
sister Irene almost made at the end of
the movie if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe for all
my regular and upcoming deleted scenes
and horror videos spoilers ahead for the
none so take care if you haven't seen it
yet as I talked about in my ending
explained video the big reveal at the
very end of the known is that Frenchie
is actually Maurice the french-canadian
farmer whose exorcism Lorraine and Ed
Warren discussed in the first conjuring
the scene is mostly a replay of the
Warren's witnessing maurices attempted
exorcism with an added quick reveal that
Val AK possessed Frankie during the
showdown at the Abbey and that this is
how Lorraine saw that horrifying vision
of a lack but the original ending is
laid out in the January 2017 script for
the nun was even more dramatic this
alternate ending is set in a small town
in Massachusetts USA after the events of
the nun the scene begins with the sound
of a woman's screaming and pleading for
her life a shotgun blasts her arm off
and then there's a kill shot to her head
the scene reveals the killer is Frenchie
aka Maurice who's sweating and has the
look of a man possessed
Maurice sits down and pulls up his
t-shirt revealing upside down crosses
bulging out of his body and his eyes
start to bleed there's a pounding on the
front door of the house which Maurice
ignores as he tries to shoot himself
however his gun fails and then ed and
Lorraine Warren burst through the door
together with a priest they see Maurice
covered in his wife's blood and a
horrified Lorraine looks across the room
at a mirror but instead of seeing
maurices reflection she sees phallic
staring back at her as Lorraine freezes
in horror Val acts snarls and then the
mirror shatters as the screen cuts to
black and the credits roll now I think
this would have been a really intense
scene to watch and not only would it
have given us a cool cameo from Patrick
Wilson Vera Farmiga who's the real-life
sister of taissa farmiga who plays
sister Irene but this alternate ending
would also have made the connection
between Valek and Lorraine
even clearer and more horrifying I
suspect the filmmakers opted to reuse
archived footage from the conjuring
instead and just reshoot some close-up
footage of the possessed Maurice with
actor Jonas block' who plays Frenchie as
it would be a lot cheaper than getting
Vera Farmiga and Patrick Wilson Plus
there would have been extra cost for the
additional set and effects for foul acts
appearance the issue with the alternate
ending as it's written in the original
script though is that it's a little
inconsistent with events established in
the country in his University lecture
Edie Warren explained that Maurice tried
to kill his wife but only managed to
shoot her in the arm before turning the
gun on himself
in this alternate ending for the nun it
seems to be the other way around in
terms of who gets killed
I'm guessing this was a case of a simple
mix up in the screenwriters head and I
think it would have been corrected if
they chosen to go ahead with the scene
another big difference in the original
ending is that French she was going to
be infected via the snake tongues Daniel
Daniel is the boy that died when father
Burke tried to exorcise him and in the
earlier script
Daniel was going to be a winged demon in
that screenplay both sister Irene and
father Burke would have witnessed the
winged demon boy vomited snake into
Frenchie's mouth the alternate script
made it clear that the winged demon boy
was one of the several forms that VALIC
takes in the movie and showing
Frenchie's possession by phallic in this
way before we see the demon gets sent
back to hell would have cleared up some
confusion about whether it's really
valack inside Frenchie
sister Irene and father Burke would also
have seen the upside-down cross is
immediately appearing under Frenchie's
skin and his eyes turning demonic French
who had also attacked them during the
final fight before disappearing and not
being seen again in the movie until that
scene where he kills his wife Jonah's
blockier said that French his role in
the film was changed after test
audiences reacted well to his character
and the filmmakers decided to give him a
more heroic part by the way that
original look from the demon boy Daniel
was a deliberate nod to descriptions of
VAX appearance in the 17th century book
of magic the Lesser Key of Solomon in
the early 2017 script the key that
father Burke discovers on sister
Victoria's dead body was a holy relic
that gave protection against Alex
influence the key literally shown a
protective light that Irene Burke and
French he had to remain within in order
to stay protected as they descended
through
Abey to find the gateway to hell the
original script also tells us how in the
past the abbess have tried to close the
portal without the keys protection and
ended up dead and under the demonic
influence of Valek an interesting
addition to the final movie which wasn't
in the original script is the use of the
blood of Christ to send valack back to
hell
in the original story the demons defeat
didn't feature any Holy Blood instead it
involved father Burke using Ballack's
name to gain dominion over him and send
him back to hell in a very similar way
to how the rain cast the demon back at
the end of the country - the thing with
that choice is that it may have felt too
repetitive whereas having Irene spit
holy blood all over VALIC instead was a
nice tie-in with how the locals and the
village always spat whenever the abbey
was mentioned in order to ward off evil
another addition to the final movie was
director Karen Hardy's decision to cover
the gateway to hell with a pool of water
Hardy wanted to add a layer of water to
give a sense of having to pass through a
transformational layer between the two
worlds it was an interesting change and
resulted in some very atmospheric and
creepy scenes such as VALIC walking on
water the twist that the abbeys nuns
were dead all along is only revealed and
the visually impressive scene in the
chapel where Irene keeps a prayer vigil
with a group of nuns in order to hold
back the lack in the original script the
reveal is not quite as spectacular
although the twist is probably clearer
the scene simply involves Irene talking
to several nuns in the room after which
Frenchie and Burke arrive and Irene
discovers nobody was actually there with
her
there were also additional scenes where
Irene Burke and Frenchie discovered the
bodies of dead tortured nuns as they
descended deeper into the Abbey which
would have been more obvious evidence
than we get in the final film that all
the nuns have been killed before Irene
and Burke arrived by the way if you're
interested in learning more about
exactly how the twist worked and how it
was foreshadowed check out my twist and
ending explained video and there's a
major change for Irene's story in the
movie was that she was never possessed
by phallic during the final fight and at
the end she decides to stay on by
herself at the Abbey with the intention
of rebuilding it and she even dons a
black habit previously worn by one of
the dead nuns to be honest this ending
for Irene would have felt really creepy
as a thought of her staying
there with the portal to Hell just
underneath the abbey while she wears a
dead nun's habit gives me the chills
so what do you think about the alternate
endings and the changes from the
original screenplay do you think they
would have improved the final film or do
you prefer what you saw on screen leave
your thoughts in the comments below
tapleft to check out some freakishly
creepy things you missed and secrets
about the nun or tap write for more
horror movie deleted scenes including a
quiet place and it if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to leave a thumbs up
and a share would be hugely appreciated
too thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers